el proyecto del futuro sistema aéreo de
combate oefcas por sus siglas en inglés
firmado en diciembre de 2022 ya es
oficial los ministros de defensa de
España Francia y Alemania se reunieron
en el cuartel general del ejército del
aire en Madrid a mis espaldas para
presentar el acuerdo por el que los tres
países participarán a partes iguales del
programa para renovar la flota de
aviones de combate de Última Generación
de la Unión Europea antes de 2040 un
proyecto de unos 8.000 millones de euros
de los que 3.000 millones Irán en esta
primera fase de investigación tecnología
y demostración lideradas por las
compañías da sol airbus e indra en
comparecencia conjunta la española
Margarita Robles aseguró que esta
inversión en defensa equivale a invertir
en paz y seguridad todos mencionaron la
actual situación geopolítica de la
guerra en Ucrania como el tema muy
preocupante Aunque el ministro de
defensa francés Sebastián insistió en
que no hay que ser mío porque el mundo
sigue girando de ahí la importancia de
mirar hacia el futuro para no ser
vasallos de nadie por su lado el
ministro alemán Boris pistorius resaltó
la relevancia de esta Alianza para
fortalecer el flanco europeo de la otan
España además aprovechó para informar de
la llegada hoy de los seis primeros
tanques leoparda Polonia que van camino
ya a Ucrania y volvió a negar
rotundamente que existan soldados
españoles o de cualquier otro país de la
otan en suelo ucranio esto después de
que la embajada rusa en España publicara
y luego tuviera que retirar a petición
de España un tuit insinuando su
presencia Margarita Robles insistió en
que este es un bulo más de la campaña de
desinformación rusa